josé espinosa gilet jaune bonsoir je
vous explique merci d'être avec nous sur
rt france on va parler d'abord du salon
de l'agriculture ce matin qui a commencé
par cette femme qui a interpellé
emmanuel macron sur le fait qu'il
refusait de voir de vous voir gilet
jaune depuis le début de ce mouvement la
réponse a été formé un groupe et puis on
va on va pouvoir discuter
vous y croyez à cette promesse je vais
vous dire
déjà en décembre 2018 il avait vu une
délégation qui devait être reçue ensuite
ça s'est très mal passé je crois qu'il
n'a pas du tout envie de disques d'abord
il a jamais discuté avec les jets des
journées il employait même cela le mou
au début oui voilà ce n'est que
maintenant qu'ils commencent à en parler
parce qu'il a un mouvement qui dure
depuis 15 mois
évidemment s'il pensait pas que ça
durerait comme ça il pensait qu'il
allait éliminer cette affaire-là en
quelques traits un tour de main c'était
fini et bien non pas ce que vous
demandez gilet jaune ne s'est pas
quelques hurluberlus
il a répondu par des mesures aussi
concrète sur wii alors garde des sceaux
disant 17 milliards tout le monde doit
se poser la question qui a bénéficié des
17 milliards 60% des français 30% des
plus pauvres n'en ont pas bénéficié tout
à fait et donc voilà c'est non il a fait
comme il fait avec le problème des
retraites pareil il répond de la même
manière c'est à dire il évacue le
problème il
il dit on va discuter à ça pour discuter
il discute d'ailleurs ils discutent seul
il discute pas dans ce débat existe
c'est le monologue et donc c'est une
conception de la démocratie qui est
quand même loin de celle que dans tous
les cas moi je développe c'est je pense
qu'il faut des confrontations politiques
qu'il faut un débat sérieux
il ya eu des débats
avec les frais il ya eu ce qu'il a
appelé le grand débat ça a été le grand
monologue pour lui effectivement il
passé quatre heures 5 heures il a même
passé sept heures à parler c'est une
prouesse suivre sur le plan comores dire
de national personnel oui individuel
c'est très bien née pour répondre au
problème non 0 d'ailleurs il n'a pas
répondu à aucune question qui lui était
posée et c'est ce qui fait que le
mouvement dure perdure et s'élargit avec
maintenant le mouvement des retraites
qui qui s'interpénètrent tout ça et là
elle la même dynamique
et puis maintenant les avocats puis les
professions de santé
on boit que des médecins démisssion jour
après jour de leurs activités
administratives tout ça montre bien
qu'il ya un ras-le-bol et puis sondage
après sondage on voit bien qu'il est en
train il est en déliquescence et les
élections municipales vont vous savez
que comment on parlera quand on aura les
résultats oui moi je vais vous
interpeller sur eric bouet qui a été
arrêté au sol en agriculture pour
rébellion ouais voilà encore une
manifestation de l'autoritarisme de cet
état c'est à dire que eric drew et comme
tout citoyenne normale et à des ht sa
place il va au salon de l'agriculture
et il voulait parler ils ont hué le
président attention il faudra compter
les choses oui mais ils ont mué c'est
normal il faut comprendre que l on
puisse cul et je trouve même que lui et
est assez léger par rapport à ce que
nous subissons depuis quand même qu'elle
soit parce qu'il ya une répression que
qu'aucun mouvement social n'a connu
c'est la première fois avec glee gilet
jaune qu'on voit une répression pareil
et donc évidemment ça énerve des gens et
ils voulaient lieu d'hier et voulait
dire on ne s'en va pas et bien heures
voilà il a été arrêté
bon explique très bon celle ci en garde
à vue c'est pas la première fois plus
qu'un président ait eu au salon de
l'agriculture tout en personne avait été
arrêtée pour ça non jamais ça faisait
partie du débat démocratique dans notre
pays mais bon avec macro c'est fini on
en voit bien qu'il ya une répression
féroce
on l'a vu à lille également on en
parlait hier de guerre ont repris lundi
avec priscilla ludo ce qui est
d'ailleurs je suis solidaire tout de
tout leur combat et je crois que le 14
mars
ça nous incite à venir manifester vous
savez qu'à une manifestation le 14 mars
à l'appel de plusieurs centaines de
personnalités de tous bords pour lutter
pour le pouvoir d'achat
non non non non non pour combattre les
violences policières pour demander la
démission de castaner pour demander
l'interdiction des le bd et des armes
non létales et pour le droit de
manifester en sécurité j'appelle tous
les gilet jaune
le mouvement ouvrier à se rassembler
massivement pour dire non ça suffit
justement il a été interpellé sur les
violences policières emmanuel macron ce
matin par cette femme gilet jaune dans
la réponse à été
il faut arrêter de sortir manifester
comme ça tout à fait raison penser mais
vous voyez bien si ce gars n'accepte pas
la contestation
or il est dans un pays qui connaît pas
son histoire
il est zen pays contestataire
fondamentalement contestataires ça fait
partie de notre adn reste en droit en
l'occurrence ça fait mais cette partie
de l'adn du peuple français mais comment
vous l'avez interpréter des autres
peuples aussi parce qu'ils sont aussi
contestataires mais ils sont souvent
déprimé et ce qui est vraiment étonnant
c'est que les pays qui maintenant
comment vire prennent des mesures
autoritaires en der leurs peuples
viennent chercher chez nous la manière
et les moyens pour pouvoir brille mais
leur peuple c'est à dire qu'on leur
donne l'exemple
macron à il a amené du nouveau 1 ça il
faut quand même c'est à vérifier
il ya il faut reconnaître qu'il a amené
renouveau dans la répression
merci beaucoup josé spinoza d'avoir
répondu à nos questions sur la route
merci